on vous en parlait hier sur france bleu
alsace on pourrait ne plus capter les
chaînes allemandes sur la tnt début 2017
vous êtes nombreux à regarder la tête
d'edf et la r d une question de forme à
la france et l'allemagne ont choisi deux
technologies différentes pour passer en
haute définition
ça ne sera plus compatible le député
président du conseil départemental du
haut rhin eric straumann vient
d'interpeller par écrit la ministre de
la culture fleur pellerin sur ce dossier
et il est notre invité ce soir pour en
parler bonsoir eric straumann à ce sujet
à vous semble important vous êtes
vous-même intel explique d'un
téléspectateur attentif à des chaînes
allemandes un coup comme beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'alsaciens je regarde
pas mal les chaînes allemandes
peuplement pour entretenir as tu peux la
langue de goethe et surtout aussi pour
arrêt de votre vision de l'actualité
internationale que la télévision
française je crois que ça les démange
culturel important pour les alsaciens
j'ai vu cette information hier soir sur
sur votre site et ça me paraissait un
peu curieux parce que je suis pas
certain de l'exactitude technique de ce
qui a été annoncé
puisque maman j'ai un téléviseur assez
récent et en fait je alors que j'habite
quelle marge sur la zone frontalière et
je n'ai pas l'impression de doit passer
par la tête et françaises pour capter
les chaînes allemandes mais je capte
directement la tnt allemande alors j'ai
de 20 ou 30 ou 40 chaînes allemandes que
je capte parfaitement et c'est pour
cette pièce c'est pour cette raison que
j'ai posé une question écrite hier soir
à la ministre de la culture et de la
communication pour voir une précision
sur ces sur cette information
parce que effectivement il ya une partie
une partie des gens qui sont en zone
frontalière qui utilisent les laits la
la tnt française mais je pense que
l'essentiel des gens d'essentiel les
gens qui habitent en zone frontalière
pour le capter directement par par les
ondes hertziennes en tnt dont compte
qu'ils reviennent d'allemagne
donc je voulais simplement avoir cette
précision technique pour rassurer les
téléspectateurs situés en zone
frontalière en cours que je ne sais pas
peut-être qu'on peut aussi capter ces
jeunes nationalement tout le territoire
national ce qui serait une bonne chose
pour la france et pour l'allemagne
vous demandez en tout cas des précisions
puisque ça pourrait effectivement si ce
n'est plus qu'un sur la tnt gratuite il
faudrait accéder par le câble ou le
satellite en tout cas là c'est un
dossier technique que vous demandez vous
demander des éclaircissements samoura
moyens aussi d'apprendre l'allemand
ouais mais pour ce technique si vous
voulez mais je ne ferai pas aussi
alarmistes que l'a été à qualité votre
votre interlocuteur qui scandent zone
frontalière on capte directement la tnt
allemand de sans difficulté et avec un
téléviseur récent on n'a pas besoin de
décodeur
une dernière question eric straumann
c'est un bon moyen aussi effectivement
d'apprendre l'allemand par la télé
notamment pour les plus jeunes
écoutez moi j'ai une bonne maîtrise de
l'allemand
tout simplement parce que quand j'étais
jeune on regardait essentiellement la
télévision allemande qui avait à
l'époque une meilleure qualité des
missions que des télévisions françaises
est d'ailleurs très longtemps moi je
pensais que les cowboys de parler
calmement allons regarder bonazza dans
la version allemande et on en a on en
garde tous de bons souvenirs merci eric
straumann d'avoir été notre invité ce
soir vous êtes président du conseil
départemental du haut-rhin bonne
continuation à vous merci à vous